are Brad and Angelina at war over their
six children I remember Angie want sole
physical custody you know it's been
nearly two months since Angie filed and
now finally Brad is firing back Brad
Pitt is requesting joint custody of his
children et has obtained the actors
response to strange wife Angelina
Jolie's divorce petition in it he
references their six children 15 year
old Maddox 12 year old pax 11 year old
Zahara 10 year old Shiloh and 8 year old
twins Vivian and Knox a source tells et
that Jolie was not surprised by Pitts
petition for joint custody the source
also says that the actor needed to
respond to Julie's divorce filing within
a certain amount of time so this was
expected so here's a question Jolie vs.
Pitt could this become a long drawn-out
custody battle well despite the dueling
custody requests our source suggests
quote the goal for the parents is to
resolve this between themselves amicably
and privately I think because they're
high-profile it will end quickly
however custody battles last a long time
as for temporary custody et has
confirmed an agreement remains in place
Pitt has had supervised visits with his
five youngest children and had his first
supervised visit with Maddox on October
19 so what's next for Brad his new movie
is about to hit theaters come with me
mom now allied is out November 23rd and
Brad is expected to attend a special
screening Wednesday night in Los Angeles
Brad Pitt right now is living in a
fishbowl he is under intense scrutiny
everything he says is going to have an
impact of the public's appearance of him
so it really behooves him to stay under
the radar